yeah hello and welcome to a new tea
session okay yes create a game is the
way to go and I still have my bullet
settings I don't think this is very
suitable form or tea sir should I
sometimes play 1+1 and I'm all I'm on my
all-time high like almost I think anyway
so let's do something else I should
probably go here right this is easier
what about a somewhat slower blitz game
let's do that five plus three we
sometimes get opponents there it's um
okay
let's go before does that look right yes
it does so with the French yeah
the exchange has served me well really
just wondered if I can do something else
just to have a bit of a change but I
really don't know other lions compared
ibly well so I'm doing this
see
okay this is an ambitious variation that
like usually tries to unbalance the game
a little bit we'll see if that works
oftentimes it is unbalanced but the main
imbalance is that black is just worse so
let's see what happens here um we need
to check is an important move to
remember in this variation
okay this is interesting
and usually not good blacks best move
here is Queen to e7 I'm here I can grab
a pawn with Queen b5 check and the usual
assessment is that it is not not enough
a problem is that it moves like Queen d7
or c6 just give away b7 and Duke is
hanging so this has to be played and now
I'm grabbing d5 so black is basically
sacrificing a full center pawn or some
Tempe and I actually do think that black
has some compensation but I don't think
it is enough which means it's nothing to
to be feared at all a5 okay
you
- smooth
one problem of a move like a five is or
specifically this is that you want to
play c5 at some stage and then the
square b5 is terminally weak it just
weakens the queenside enormous lame I
can play a four but I want to speed up
my development and get closer to
canceling so let's do this I didn't
really think about grabbing another pawn
I think this is probably a bit too much
but
it is not clear what his compensation is
after I'm taking the second pawn
absolutely not
yeah okay Queen d3 is kind of the normal
move let's do it
of course I've moved my queen quite a
bit e to b5 d 5b 3d fits on and now I'm
back on D Warner but again it's a center
pawn this is very important I'm not
definitely not advocating to move the
Queen all over the place in the opening
but if you get a center pawn
have to consider it okay so c6 is not
exactly the most active move ever
um
completely certain how I should set this
up
c4 and 93 is the most ambitious way to
play this but you can also play C 3
Bishop g5 and develop
I came I am NOT certain
see 3 is also fun stabilized system
and Bishop g5 well I can also play d5
this is something that I should take
into account
yeah this makes quite some sense I'm
threatening d6 to win a piece and if I
manage to play c4 93 then this is a
fantastically strong extra pawn on e5
and I'm a little bit behind here
clockwise but you know it's five plus
three so
I have enough time
see for to allow
93
there's also quite a reasonable move
the air horn but okay let's press c4 I'm
a little bit I'm I'm really slow here
yeah so this is something that I could
have prevented with night III not sure
that that was necessary preventing it I
mean but only that I could have done
okay take it
I thought you would at least try to get
it back
I'd be six and it's actually quite
likely that one of the points he will
drop one of those but I already have
quite
a good amount of material so
I don't think
[Music]
this is much of an issue
case sample should be
I just got the square to develop so
let's do it how many points do I have
three three pawns up
so now I can trade trade wait half of
the board so I think I'm doing this
would be M
[Music]
yeah I mean he can't do that just like I
did not actually think about this way of
playing
rookie one maybe
speed up development
No
you
yeah three points is just to be too much
even though they are they are not the
most
porns ever admittedly
akise w po hunts are not very strong
[Music]
no I know I'm threatening made and
create a success on the radar I think
probably wookie one here asking him
about the e4 pawn
and Ruby aid I can take you for of
course because there's made on g7
and that's the end of it
yeah so the opening here is key already
and this is one thing that is clearly
something mentioned in favor of the
exchange variation that all the
ambitious tries for black are not that
great Bishop g4 is one of them if you
know h3 Bishop h5 we need to check you
have excellent chances for an advantage
um the thing is that only Queenie iseven
prevents this check on b5 and then white
plays Bishop b3 Knight c3 castles Queen
side and g4 and white is actually better
in this variation just an interesting
and kind of non symmetrical position
I mean it's symmetrical in terms of pawn
structure at the center of it the the
way the game develops is very very
interesting um and better for white
simply the move Bishop g4 does not have
a really good reputation among the
additions and also knight c6 is one of
those moves that it's often mentioned to
unbalance and I think after Bishop b5
why does not actually better but a bit
more comfortable I think I would still
prefer white in these situations in
particular if black played this in order
to unbalance he's not getting very far
so let's do another 5 + 3
ah
if it Roman we don't know so a Sicilian
Jim maybe the open can always promote
that
oh no he goes from probably a Kings
Indian attack with g3 now and yeah this
is a harmless version of the Kings
Indian attack
because I can set up the board winning
on center this is very comfortable yeah
and it looks like honestly why does not
[Music]
not quite well-versed in what to do this
kind of setup with a form is not
dangerous at all I mean the whole
opening is not dangerous but this is
very easy for black to handle as why
this is not even getting anything on the
queenside
i'm usually even able to play d5 you
have the very comfortable choice between
playing d5 or f5
and I have tried both actually
you know this looks more like an f5 type
of position because
yes
I just wonder I have the time to play
King age seven and this is a tidy move
that I like to make
to keep
okay
this is kind of not connected what is
doing
one and his night maneuvers leading
nowhere
leave him in my mind the only way to
play this position for white is to
immediately start action on the
queenside in this way this is actually
interesting and it leads to a position
where I would definitely prefer black
but objectively it's probably equal and
now in this situation the only question
is how much better is black now because
you know this matters I have a fantastic
central control white should try to
somehow yeah throw a spanner in the
works kind of disturb medium in the
center if I get enough time to play
let's say Nagi 65 I'm all as winning
yeah and I think this is something like
this is the right way to to play this
with white so immediately trying to as I
said it disturbed me now I can take this
twice a pawn takes pawn takes pawn takes
when then Knight see - he has chances to
get get this back
the alternatives efore but then he will
go d5
yeah before is a good move
and maybe puts
my immediate f5 a little bit into
question because I'm not entirely sure
how I play this now hmm I can play a
takes he takes Knight takes grab the
pawn but my position is a little bit
loose after that
it's a little bit loose
you
Jambi 45 is not so great
okay what else can I do I can also play
F form
five
it looks a little bit better but
and still not
still not happy about it
you
um Kim I can't play it takes he takes
night eggs
whereas I said it it looks loose and I
kind of
looks really loose
you
95 unfortunate is also not playable I'm
kind of kind of
don't quite know what to do him
so that's a really annoying annoying
idea d5 come on let's play this I mean I
already have spent far too much time and
I have to have to just make a move
yeah maybe an f5 was indeed a little bit
too early I was provoked by this move a
5 summer we just kind of completely not
fitting into anything and then I went f5
maybe maybe that was premature I don't
know because I have time and I can't
play whatever roopd ate first or
something like that um you know I don't
know let's let's focus on the actual
game so he took on a form and now I can
I can now take on D form and then I take
this is a possibility or this one
yeah let's tickle and try to get control
over d5
I did not really expect this one
no g 6f to play anyway so doesn't matter
all that much
want to play anyway in many cases
now what's going on if he moves the
night
whose c2f Bishop f5 which is definitely
fine for black
you
it's important that if he moves the
night away I cannot play Bishop h3
because Bishop takes h3 Queen f3 Knight
g5 check blunders the Queen this is a
nice little idea otherwise Bishop h3
would be kind of attractive
so after you
keep that in mind that Bishop h3 could
be technically vulnerable
now it is time to think a little bit
maybe white has something better than
moving the night and it probably should
try to find something better than that
there is night age four in this position
but quite certain that this actually
Nets anything I can't play 97 norm
yeah probably 97
okay now
don't think I've got much of voice I
have to take
you
okay now why what is what happens after
Bishop takes d5 is now a g5 check
somehow deadly I can take that no I
don't see why why can I not take this
under this right well what is the big
point here
you
now that was just a blunder I think
Oh
[Music]
yeah there was a sudden end of
everything so he went deformed and I
couldn't quite couldn't quite make it
work okay the initial engine reaction is
at f4 is actually the best move so I at
the end intuitively made the right
decision one thing that I didn't like it
all was this one then when I which are
called Toulouse the problem was that
here you want to take with the bishop
otherwise the structure is just it does
this structure it's just too bad yeah
you shouldn't go for this on general
grounds and here I thought and I'd see
to when I'm in trouble yeah this is true
actually yeah what I meant with to Lu
says there are all kinds of things going
on in particular the idea Queen loops we
need to those two pieces are not really
protected so the normal move he would
like to make is this and then there's
Queen e2 there is a six yeah stuff like
that I've called Toulouse for like so
this this didn't work and that kind of
reduces the options as d5 is a threat
this is definitely good for white
unfortunately as something like this all
of a sudden looks great for white yeah
blacks position is again weakened and
you don't really have anything great
available um so I did not really make a
mistake with their five but as I already
suspected as the engine confirms you
should make an improvement move like
let's say rook 88
expecting some action coming and then
everything is nicely set up and their
five I mean it's probably not a mistake
but maybe a bit too early so d4f form he
took it
and oke takes is given as better even
okay yeah I thought about that briefly
because here it looks like I can maybe
take yeah this is a bit of a different
situation because IKEA
the night is still here Sam yeah it's
very unclear I I wanted to make a quick
move simply because of the time but it
seems that d5 now is really good for
white okay so I take he takes and yam
understandable him I can do this but
then the pony is extremely strong
and if I take on e6 and white recaptures
with the Bishop I don't have a good
square for the Queen
the problem is also that the light
squares us we get something like
oops nope that was wrong
something like that could be very
dangerous for my king I don't have a
light squared bishop anymore so that was
lucky yeah that's how d5 was very good
for white it seems
probably have to play this position here
with the this one in here and then try
to play this but not good
can you play the check
and now g6 again d5
so if you're not actually good for white
so you should just take here okay I did
not actually expect this to be so bad
for me
but this seems to be according to the
calm very good for white
so it was this was not only losing the
game basically but also giving away the
opportunity to have a good position okay
now let's go for more games
you
Bobbo
whoa
I am playing the improved Karpov
variation as it is called nowadays
Karpov always worthless Knight f6 early
on and in the approved cup of you delay
this
decision
sometimes 97 for example can be
interesting
you
one of the reasons why 97 is interesting
is exactly this scenario
because now yeah briefly
should you forward now the night comes
to f5
and we have everything lined up to
pressurize the pond and Whitefield's
inclined to push it forward now here my
bishop is pretty good
you
okay
you
that it's normally more of a nice square
so if I play h5 here now he cannot move
the night to good square so let's do
that the idea to push h4 here it's not
some kind of caveman chess just I think
good because I'm doing something with my
bishop okay so he gives me complete
control over the dark squares which is
something that I happily take
you
an interesting situation would arise
after g-form
I think I can play a knight III then
night III Shoji 493 with the fork and if
he takes it rook takes and then I'm
threatening
Hey threatening quite a lot under in
terms of discovered attacks okay um I
can still play 93-year but I think it's
more
well I can I can I get to Bishop them
sting
habit I'm not I'm not liking it that
much but wait um what about it's
actually interesting so I'm taking this
first
I just spotted that after rookie 1/2
Knight to g4
and this is some very annoying
how does he cover this even
night h3 maybe that's not exactly a
dream move
I thought night xf2 now would simply win
what am i overlooking
takes a few I doesn't have some damn I
look in here
you
let's do it
you
I'm threatening tons of discovery Sam
there as Victor below-ground coin did so
nicely the black shag on a7 is
absolutely killing now on Knight e4 has
said even stronger than grabbing
material 94 they can play King edge to
win them up meeting
but
get into
turn trouble
and more time trouble than necessary at
least I'm a little bit behind anyway on
the clock
the thing is I think I should not
actually
playful mate is the thing icky Queen
age six is close to mate you can try
Queen age to where I go g6
and
I have this very simple plan King g7
Bishop d7 Luke h8
not much that he can do about it
okay
a g4 probably also us the job
you
removes the bishop there is 94 maybe
you
maybe there were quicker ways to to do
it but
it is not too bad
hmm even though I'm not winning
immediately at least I don't I don't see
how
he's completely boxed in here
you
Knight g4 which would almost work with
and he doesn't really have a move him
what is what can you what can you play
not much okay I'm going for a rematch
m4
the carro
you
and this variation like is very
wittingly is the word that I was looking
for
I'm giving up the bishop pair
you
and yeah this is a pretty easy position
to assess it's something
we're white is always going to enjoy a
slide pool with the bishops but like is
of course extremely to be solid
you just sitting there with e66 and
awaits proceedings so the same
night will come to a six-year I guess
then to c7
okay so
quite certain way I should put this
bishop it's actually not bad on Siwon
but I need the rook of course
you
yeah so I'm not unhappy about Bishop on
c1 on c1 that cannot be traded so it's
there for for later use so to say and
now I can continue trying to slowly
expand
the main thing is that black is not it's
not easy for black to play c500 five
it's it's difficult to do in the first
place like just an end and it's opening
up the position for my pieces so if he
goes c5 my bishop on f3 is not unhappy
and if it was a five it might lead to
further trades but it's difficult to
play this move so this is a surprising
decision honestly because I'm opening up
the position now and I've got this
pressure here wouldn't be seven
we should f form you know you don't
quite know what he's doing
56 is blundering b7 I think
and yeah the Queen
doesn't have a clearly good square yeah
here I got before
not sure it could be a bit too early to
play
in general I would like to advance the
pawns that is absolutely clear but the
question is about the timing
[Music]
particularly the move 95 could be
rotating
to have the pants ready to further
advance
hmm
you
yeah
and move like c4 also
comes into consideration but he's got
Bishop d4 in that case and the bishop is
pretty well placed there
okay I'm playing the
really see how else to make headway I
mean I'm not unhappy about this but I
wasn't completely sure if this is the
right way to do it
this prevents 95a think due to the poor
Nguyen
and my ideas to play the Queen to b3 and
then later C form
I'm sure there was a good move but we'll
see
you
it's not actually so easy to place c4 as
before as hanging so
okay yeah he looks at at the pawn yeah
ad at the square of it um it's not easy
for him to put anything on it because
I'm just maybe he wants to play PL b5
I have Bishop d7 as what I was trying to
say
unsuccessfully
you
or maybe he plays Quincy for
I can take take b7
there must always be good for wired in
some way
in to some degrees maybe the better way
to phrase that so I'm not sure how much
I'm better but I'm sure that I am better
unless you win see a porn but I don't
think that's possible
I have Roo k1 yeah
[Music]
yeah the the issue for black is simply
that I've got two against one and it's
close to promotion already there are
those two points are very far advanced
and I have the promotion square Bishop
so something like a 5 B 6 a 6 a 7 is
going to be very very quick and we don't
quite know how is preventing the
promotion I have 33 seconds this is
plenty
yeah
that is an important detail No so I'm
taking this or
I can take it so it's good v6 also was a
good move
so keeping the spawn will be one for
rugby aid
he's also he's got a big back rank big
background background back rent problem
you
after Bishop f4 GF forum you can tell me
it couldn't take because of me um okay
I'm not going for a rematch thank you -
just want to look look quickly yeah the
thing is I think that this is the Quincy
for years I think a mistake um them are
probably even queen a6 I think black
should be a man but the engine is
actually already condemning blacks
position pretty severely
I mean if he does not get any
substantial play in the next moose I
mean I'm very good yeah with with the
points coming i have those super strong
bishops but it felt to me that it
shouldn't be so terrible for black but
it's already pretty bad this is
definitely very bad yeah this
disposition
plus plus plus three almost yeah yeah so
it's what I said basically he cannot
stop my pawns and yeah that sets us what
it is
okay so let's get in one more game
one more game it's again Nawab oh I
don't mind to play guys multiple times I
just wanted to have a look at deem
at the engine evaluation of one of those
critical positions now yeah g3 is what I
usually do
but I can play Queen's Gambit it's not
like I'm completely
helpless if that happens
this line is quite interesting and
something that I had analyzed for my
keep it simple deform
ultimately did not use
maybe should be six it's not a bad move
the move Bishop g6 in fact and turn out
to be a mistake I will show you later
this is actually fairly solid reply
black
if I remember this correctly I'm just
continuing to develop castles and so on
and I keep the night on edge for for a
moment
see how he handles this
see five is not yet
not yet a thing
yummmy maybe he can play c5
[Music]
why'd remember how this discontinued
you
okay I feel bad with the night on h4 in
the long run it looks a little bit loose
okay so then that cannot be a big issue
for me
getting my night back into the game so
wrong lame he wants to play oh did I
blunder stuff
and the unprotected state of this bishop
I mean Knight c5 but I can move it away
yeah this is unlike
this I like forward
I mean black took on c4 this is not um
like necessarily a bad decision but it's
something that
should be made very consciously because
I still have the better center with e3
and d4 and the bishop on g7 is not so
effective against it
doesn't look like and maybe he can play
c5 actually still the unprotected bishop
Oh
yeah okay it's not going to kill me if
that happens but
Oh
don't understand it what I was preparing
me for his just just going into this
move or I mean now I'm threatening me
five even
I didn't go a form
year because Bishop g4 I don't want him
to trade this bishop off because it's
all misplaced the bishop ei the problem
with blacks positioning is he has a bit
he has too many pieces
like after trading one or two minor
pieces I think it would be fine
and this doesn't look fine this is a
very annoying move now Bishop f4 what do
you do about that
so having a look at the c5 square
Bishop takes d4 I play Bishop f4
okay so I can play Bishop f4 and then
then he has to go back to d8
that doesn't look very attractive
you know let's do it
yeah
twenty-eight
do you wanna
this building
okay yeah you can go there but I don't
know if that is said any better
Canon's do this
95 in some cases
I teach
okay let's this is a bit lazy chess I
know but
to covering D 495 immediately maybe was
possible now it is a threat to play 95
and he's going back prophylactically
Knight takes c6 is a threat so it's even
a threat now
let's do it
96b takes night X this is such a huge
fork both rooks I'm on c7 I'm on e seven
like if it's my move now night X is six
just wins material absolutely absolutely
sure and I think this is also winning
material
[Music]
yeah it must win material impossible not
to
the thing is in always night xe7 is the
thing winning in the Queen iam and now
even if the night is just was just
hanging yeah I can just take the night
and I am quite a bunch of material up
and he's still in the forks and yeah and
whatnot everything at the same time
[Music]
no I actually want to end the session
here 45 minutes is a good is a good time
for that all right I hope you enjoyed it
I think I even gained some points not
not much but some points and we had some
interesting games I hope you enjoyed it
the next time bye bye